[Musique]
et on va accueillir je vous dis deux
personnes sous qtf non mais c'est moi
j'en ai jamais vu ouis par exemple non
c'est voilà on en parle tout le temps et
on a envie d'avoir donc leur témoignage
alors sachez au qtf ce qui veut dire
obligation le territoire français alors
ils ont une obligation de quitter le
territoire français c'est deux jeunes
adultes qtf qui souhaitent nous parler
de leur attachement à la France et ils
vont être sur notre plateau donc on
espère que ça voilà parce que je veux
pas non plus pr des risques et que ça se
passe mal pour après voilà ils veulent
témoigner et ils veulent nous dire que
ils se sentent très bien intégrés et que
ils ne se sentent pas de quitter le
territoire il s'agit de Mohamed Amin et
de sibora sont accompagnés de leur
avocat Maître
Mad mais avant tout on regarde Gérald
armanin et ses explications concernant
la loi immigration et ces deux personnes
qtf seront à côté de nous sont là à tout
de suite parti les dispositions qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la loi et qui nous
empêche d'appliquer lestf c'est tous les
étrangers qui résident en France depuis
l'âge de ces 13 ans l'étranger résident
en France régulièrement depuis 10 ans
l'étranger en France régulièrement
depuis 20 ans l'étranger parent d'un
enfant français nous proposons que nous
puissions appliquer les eqtf pour toutes
ces personnes ce que prévoit le Tex
c'est si quelqu'un est arrivé avant
l'âge de 13 ans et qu'à 19 ans il a été
auteur de crime permettre de l'éloigner
je v remercier maître Mad bonsoir voà je
disad ou Mad Mad tout simplement c'est
une question qui revient Mo les gens
m'appellent Hanouna ou les gens
m'appellent Hanouna voilà comme vous
vlez c'est Mad très bien ben merci en
tout cas d'être avec nous parce que
c'est vous allez voir ça c'est une
séquence vraiment qu'on ne peut voir que
dans touche pas mon poste en direct et
regardez on voit Mohamed et sibora et
c'est vrai que ils sont sous au qtf
c'estàdire sous une obligation de
quitter le territoire français déjà la
première question euh j'ai envie de
poser
ou à au mettre ou bien vous deux c'est
pourquoi vous êtes sous auqtf pourquoi
vous êtes en obligation de quitter le
territoire français parisque vous êtes
étudiante pour vous sibora vous êtes
étudiante en quoi euh je suis étudiante
en LEA langue étrangère et appliqué
d'accord depuis combien de temps euh bah
là j'ai fait tout mon parcours ici
d'accord depuis le collège j'ai eu mon
brevet j'ai eu le bac et là je suis en
2e année et d'ord d'accord et vous
Mohamed bah moi je suis venu à l'âge de
14 ans d'accord j'ai eu mon brevet ici
j'étais au collège à landosski
j'habitais à Bologne avant ah oui à côté
oui oui et après bah j'ai fait un CAP
Agent de sécurité ou et je l'ai eu et
entre deux j'ai fait une erreur que
fallait pas le faire et c'est ça qui a
fait que vous étiez sousoccut oui
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait comme
erreur comme ça on dit tout bah j'étais
bah la veille de l'anniversaire de ma
tante là où où je vis chez elle oui j'ai
bah j'étais avec des amis on était
alcoolisé et et bah du coup ils ont pris
on était à côté de la moto ils l'ont
pris et et de là on s'est fait
interpeller à côté on l'a pas volé on
s'est fait interpell à côté de la moto
ils nous ont pris pouro c'est un mec qui
a pris vos potes qui a pris une moto qui
a volé une moto et vous ées à côtéà vous
étiz dans la bande quoi oui voilà donc
et et derrière au qtf oui derrière au
qtf j'ai eu un jugement j'ai eu un
jugement et le tribunal il m'a bah il
nous a ils m'ont donné une deuxième
chance comme je suis en étude et j'ai
que des bons résultats que des que des
félicitations que j'ai des soutiens de
tous mes profs et bah du coup et
pourquoi c'est quoi alors votre deuxième
chance euh bah j'ai eu un stage de
citoyenneté et une Amand à payé le juge
il a d aujourd'hui pourquoi vous êtes
encore sous qtf bah je sais pas j'ai eu
une peine et là je j'ai de double peine
double peine juste et et vous sibora
pourquoi vous êtes sous au qtf bah moi
c'est quand j'ai eu mes 18 ans j'ai fait
la demande comme majeur j'ai eu un
récipic pendant presque 1 an et là ils
m'ont répondu avec un keV j'ai pas tout
à fait vous êtes de quelle origine je
suis albanaise d'accord et vous tunisien
tunisien bon et donc là vous êtes sous
au qtf mais et vous êtes vous êtes avec
votre famille ici je suis avec mon bah
le mari de ma tante qui est français et
ma tante qui est aussi française et on
vit ensemble on partage les mêmes trucs
ensemble lui il est catholique moi je
suis on partage tout ensemble on est on
habite ensemble il y a que le respect et
moi je je je je vais tout vous dire euh
pourquoi je voulais vous recevoir ce
soir et je pense que pour les
téléspectateurs c'est important aussi il
est 19h52 on est en direct nous et je
vous dis on a souvent eu le discours ici
on s'est dit pourquoi tous les qtf euh
et rayon l'a dit
aussi ne soyez ne devez pas devait
quitter le territoire s'il avait une
obligation de quitter le territoire il
fallait qu'il le quitte et c'est vrai
qu'on avait envie de voir des profils
parce que quand on vous voit tous les
deux euh quand on vous écoute on on on
se dit en fait pourquoi vous êtes euh
sous au qtf maîre pourquoi parce que
même si là euh il est il est vous es
aujourd'hui tu es nationalité tunisienne
oui c'est ça et vous nationalité
albanaise oui c'est ça donc mais vous
vous avez combien d'lit ou pas euh de
quoi vous avez combien d'élit de com
vous avez commis un délit ou pas du
infraction infra jamais jamais non
jamais et pourquoi vous êtes sous qtf
pourquoi elle est sous qtf alors
expliquez-nous m merci alors c'est vrai
tout d'abord merci de les recevoir parce
que c'est important on parle beaucoup de
d'qtf on se moment dans les médias parle
beaucoup d'immigration qu'on met très
souvent en lien avec Ben tout simplement
la délinquence donc c'est important on y
reviendra peut-être plus tard et c'est
important de voir des visages et de voir
des parcours pour comprendre que parfois
les obligations de quitter les
territoires français c'est pas forcément
pour des personnes qui sont dans la
délinquence ou terrorisme nous je peux
vous dire ce qu' ce qu'on voit alors je
dis moi ce que j'avais en tête et ce que
ce qu'il avaient en tête pratiquement
tous ici je pense vraiment c'est pour
nous voyez les terroristes parce que les
der divers c'était souvent des TF cétait
c'était 5000 otf dangereux et qui ont on
disait qu'il fallait mettre 10 policiers
derrière untf fich F et nous on avait
dit non ces gens-là on va pas mettre 10
policiers derrière un gars autant autant
qu'ils repartent d'où ils viennent
autant quand on sait la destination d'où
ils viennent quand je vois les deux
personnes que j'ai là qu'on fait des
études en France qu'on passa des
diplômes en France ont eu des brevets en
France ces gens-là c'est du cas par cas
ces gens-là ils ont pas à retourner dans
un pays qui est en guerre ouou qu'ils
ont fuit ou peu importe ou qui ou qui
préfère être là plutôt qu'en Tunisie non
mais qui préfère être là plutôt qu'en
Tunisie parce qu'il pens qu'il a une
meilleure vie ici moi mon père quand il
est parti du Maroc pour venir ici c'est
pour avoir une meilleure vie ici c'est
pas
pour PL on on va y revenir parce que
justement ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
quand on a un refus de séjour donc quand
on rentre pas dans un cas de plein droit
donc de délivrance de tytre de séjour de
plein droit la préfecture peut assortir
le refus de séjour d'une obligation de
quitter le territoire Francé elle peut
mais dans on va dire la majorité des cas
tous les refus de séjour sont assortis
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français il y a très peu de dossierers
où finalement on donne ce qu'on appelle
les refus simples et là dans ces deux
dossiers c'est des dossiers on va dire
plutôt euh habituels mais en même temps
atypique parce que ce sont des jeunes
qui arrivent après l'âge de 13 ans donc
le plein droit c'est avant 13 ans alors
tunisien c'est même avant 10 ans parce
que c'est l'accord franco-tunisien qui
s'applique donc il ne sont pas dans le
plein droit ils sont arrivés à 14 ans
tous les deux donc pour sibora elle
arrivé on va dire quelques mois trop
tard si elle est arrivée à l'âge de 13
ans elle avait de plein droit un typre
de séjour c'est pas le cas donc elle
rentre pas dans le plein droit
d'ailleurs on lui délivre un récipissé
donc elle arrive à préfecture elle
dépose son dossier répissé et on se dit
qu'avec les résultats scolaires qu'elle
a parce qu'elle a un baccalauréat en
France un brevet elle est en 2e année de
langue étrangère appliqué avec des
bonnes notes que ça va passer qu'on va
tenir compte de son ancienneté de séjour
et son parcours scolaire et non là le
préfet n'en tient pas compte en
indiquant que les deux parents sont en
situation irrégulière et que donc elle
peut retourner dans son pays d'origine
sans qu'il y ait d'atteinte à sa vie
privé et familiale et là où où
effectivement c'est un petit peu
compliqué c'est que on va revenir aussi
sur le cas de de de de Monsieur amine
c'est que ces personnes-là au départ
quand elles sont arrivées en France
c'était pas leur choix ce sont des ce
sont des des mineurs donc c'est le choix
des parents ça aussi il faut peut-être
en tenir compte et elles ont quelque
part déjà une première fois un choix des
parents où on décide de les changer
totalement de vie et encore une fois
donc là elles vont s'intégrer elles vont
s'investir tous les deux que des amis
français avec un parcours tout à fait je
dirais exemplaire on va voir les
résultats scolaires de de Mohamed Amin
les professeurs ont fait une lre de
soutien en disant il est exemplaire et
pour autant on se retrouve avec des
situations où légalement ils peuvent le
faire POS tous nos téléspectateur à
19h56 c'est vous avez une obligation de
quitter le territoire français et vous
êtes sur notre plateau ce soir comment
ça se fait bah en fait moi
personnellement je fais attention et là
même quand j'irai à mon lycée et là je
passe mon bac bah j'ai j'ai peur je
stresse même pour aller à mon lycée
c'estd que là si vous si vous faites
contrôler bah voilà quand vous vous
devzour plac au centre de rétion pour
ê moi j'ai ma tante ici c'est comme ma
mère elle a pas elle a jamais eu
d'enfant et je peux pas le je peux pas
c'est pour ça je suis venu en France je
sais mais euh Mohamed vous avez pas peur
là de de vous montrer ce soir en direct
bah non j'ai peur oui mais j'assume
voilà j'ai j'ai pas le choix j'ai pas le
choix si vous si vous avez un contrôle
euh qu'est-ce qui se passe bah un centre
et après il remè en Tunisie d'accord et
pourquoi vous avez quitté la Tunisie
quand vous aviez 14 ans ma tante elle a
pas eu d'enfants d'accord
voilà mon père il est décédé j'avais 5
ans quand il était voilà et bah du coup
ma ma mère elle pouvait pas et du coup
je suis allé avec ma tante pour qu'elle
pour qu'elle m'aide et pour pour habiter
avec elle quoi bien sûr et je suis venu
légalement ici je suis venu avec un visa
je suis pas venu par l'Italie je suis
venu légalement mais voilà alors à
préciser excusez-moi il a eu des
documents de circulation pour est Trang
mineur c'est veut dire que toute la
minorité il éta j'tais j'étais en règle
sibora vous pourquoi vous si vous aussi
vous si vous êtes contrôlé vous aussi
vous retournez en Albanie i c'est c'est
la même chose oui on a mais en plus vous
vous la alors je je dis tout ce qui se
passe sur les réseau euh Mohamed ils
disent bon c'est vrai que Mohamed il a
des notes incroyables et cetera il a
l'air voilà franchement mais mais ils
disent il a il a commis une petite
infraction euh pour vous euh ils
comprennent pas en fait pourquoi donc
c'est c'est quoi la raison ah bah elle
entre pas dans un casadre délivrance de
plein droit donc on peut lui assortir le
refus de ses jour donc c'est pour ça que
je vous dis voy voyez comment c'est moi
moi je vais prendre 2 minutes je vais
quand même prendre euh bon la défense du
du ministre de l'intérieur vous rendez
compte il faudrait en fait c'est
vraiment au cas par cas vous rendez
compte ce qu'il faudrait faire il
faudrait qu'il y ait des personnes qui
soit euh donc euh donc nommé par le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour statut par
le ministère de l'Intérieur pour qu'il
fasse des entretiens avec chacun des otf
des enquêtes et des enquêtes et qui les
revoi peut-être tous les 6 mois pour
voir comment ils évoluent ou tous les 3
mois vous rendez compte c'est c'est
énormément de moyens en fait c'est ça
l'histoire parce que nous là ce qu'on a
fait voilà je suis sûr que n'importe
quelle personne censé qui fait un
entretien avec Mohamed ou avec sibora il
se disent bon quand on parle avec eux
ils ont pas l'air d'être un danger pour
la France ils ont l'air parfaitementgré
ils veulent travailler ils ont des notes
excellentes voilà donc le l'histoire
c'est vraiment alors
problème c'est que dans une loi c'est on
essaie voilà c'est c'est c'est on essaie
de généraliser donc forcément c'est pas
au cas par cas et c'est vrai qu'il y a
certains cas avec certaines lois et
certaines décisions qui doivent être
prises au cas par cas c'est fou on en a
parlé la dernière fois sur une autre
décision je sais plus quoi on disait
c'est au cas par cas mais là vraiment
c'est c'est très compliqué vraiment qui
qui j'aimerais voilà qui pense ici que
Mohamed ou doivent quitter le territoire
et doivent honorer leur qtf dites la
vérité qui on voit qu'on est pas
dans dans face à non mais dit
dites-le non mais est-ce qu'il y en a ou
pas parce que c'est comme un moi moi je
vous dis quand je les vois sup y a des
règles ah oui pour vous il y a des
règles il y a des règles il y a des lois
à partir moment il rentre pas dans le
cadre de la loi qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire que lo loi la
loi tu lu dis pourquoi tu es sur la loi
c'est vrai elle a raison quand on dit
qu'on est sur la loi la lo lo dans ton
sens derère la loi la loi là c'est mon
avenir qu' est mon avenir qu'il est en
jeu là c'est moi son je peux pas je peux
pas avec mon diplôme français je peux
rien faire en Tunisie ils veulent me
ramener en Tunisie pourquoi faire je
vais faire quoi fin d'année bien sûr non
mais si vous veniez d'un pays en guerre
de Syrie ou d'un autre pays comme ça en
guerre vot VI soit en danger et nous on
va en vacances en Tunisie donc j'ai du
mal à comprendre que vous soyez ça soit
ça soit
difficile avenir il est en France oh
bien sûr je sais mon avenir il est en
France si je mais un jour je veux faire
ma vie en France je je fournir une
famille en France je va faire tout en
France et pourquoi je j'aurais pas cette
chance é élevé par sa tante française ça
ce qu' nous a dit Mohed ce serait un
drame pour vous de retourner en Tunisie
mais bien sûr ça c'est la pire peine
que ferie quoi feriez quoi comment
feriez quoi vous avez qui là-bas en
Tunisie j'ai j'ai ma mère et ma sœur
d'accord mais vous parz quoi si vous je
je sais pas comment je vais finir je
sais je sais pas là même mes amis
d'enfance ça y est je je me rappelle
plus de personne JeanMichel
oui non je sais pas c'est évidemment
c'est des cas par cas mais moi je sais
pas à partir moment où vous n'êtes pas
françaisêes pas français vous avez pas
de Ty de séjour ben à un moment faut VO
j'étais jeune quand j'ai bah c'est la
France qui m'a élevé à 14 ans je suis
ven si j'étais en Tunisie là qu'on me
dise vous êtes pas tunisien vous nes pas
de papier faut repartir en France je
crois que je dirais bah
mais vous aimez votre pays j'imagine la
Tunisie j'aime la
France je partage les mêmes je partage
les mêmes valeurs que les mêmes de la
République et je voilà on vit dans la
même dans le même pays non non mais s
plus français que tunisien plus fr plus
français ou tunisien je suis plus
français que tunisien et ça se voit là
qu même quand quand je parle pas
français ça manque ça me manque mais moi
c'est beau un mec qui dit ça je suis
désolé les gars je suis désolé il y il y
en a qui CCH sur la France il y a des
mecs c'est vra ils on des bien sûr moi
mon avenir je le vois pas ailleurs je le
vois pas ailleurs à part ici là j'ai 19
ans j'ai 19 ans je vois mon mon avenir
partir en voilà j'aimerais bien oui
Daniel je crois qu' est dans le même
avie que jeanmich Jean-Michel B un petit
peu alors le truc c'est ça c'est que
voilà quand on connaît les gens
évidemment qu'on a envie de vous aider
on a envie que vous restiez mais il y a
quelque chose aussi quand même qui est
un peu inaudible c'est que vous avez une
maman et une sœur dans votre pays qui
n'est pas en guerre alors bien sûr
maintenant je comprends que vous soyez
habitué vous soyez bien ici mais
comprenez que c'est un petit peu
inaudible avec tout ce qu'on tout t tous
les problèmes que pose l'immigration
c'est inaudible mais maintenant vous
êtes en face de moi évidemment que j'ai
envie y a des gens qui y a des gens qui
disent sur Twitter il y a des gens qui
disent sur Twitter si on laisse passer
pour Mohamed c'est la porte ouverte et
et après derrière voilà non mais non
mais c'est ce qu'il disent voilà donc à
un moment c'est ça le truc c'est que on
manque de moyens même à ce niveau-là je
suis désolé on manque de moyens parce
que il faudrait je dis faire des entreti
il faud chunentre si B à vous si vous
retournez en Albanie ce sera un drame
pour vous oui bien sûr vous avez qui en
Albanie euh j'ai ma famille est ils sont
tous
là tous en France toute la famille
d'accord et aujourd'hui vous vivez
est-ce que vous vivez la peur au ventre
de de vous dire ouais je vais retourner
dans mon pays oui bien sûr parce que là
comme j'ai tous mes amis ils sont ici
même quand je parle avec des gens et
tout ils me disent quand je je leur dis
que je suis pas Français ils me dit ah
bah ça se voit même pas que tu es pas
française et tout tu as pas l'accent et
tout tout euh là j'ai tout mon avenir
euh je vais euh pardon je vais j'ai là
je vais je vais stressé euh là je vais
avoir mon diplôme j'espère bientôt puis
je vais faire un master en formation des
enseignants euh puis pour enseigner vous
aimez plus la France ou l'Albanie la
France bien sûr en Albanie j'ai pas vous
avvez pas d'attache là-bas j'ai pas de
souvenirs j'ai pas trop de
ma Tirana Jean
Tirana je connais pas trop pour vous
c'est la capitale un peu deure fera pas
de mal Gill verd merci Gill